data sets and data frames equals love
although the processing functions of the
datasets library will cover most of the
cases needed to train a model there are
times when you'll need to switch to a
library like pandas to access more
powerful features or high-level apis for
visualization
fortunately the datasets library is
designed to be interoperable with
libraries like pandas as well as numpy
pytorch tensorflow and jacks
in this video we'll take a look at how
we can quickly switch our data to pandas
data frames and back
as an example let's suppose we're
analyzing supreme court cases from
switzerland
as usual we download our dataset from
the hub using the load dataset function
and you can see that the first element
of the training set is an ordinary
python dictionary with various fields of
interest
now suppose that before we train any
models we'd like to explore the data a
bit
for example we might be interested in
knowing which legal area is the most
common
or we might want to know how the
languages are distributed across regions
answering these questions with the
native arrow format isn't easy but we
can quickly switch to pandas to get our
answers
the way this works is that by using the
set format method we will change the
output format of the data set from
python dictionaries to pandas data
frames
as you can see in this example each row
in the data set is represented as a data
frame so we can slice the whole data set
to get a single data frame of the corpus
the way this works under the hood is
that the data sets library changes the
magic get item method of the data set
the get item method is a special method
for python containers that allows you to
specify how indexing works
in this case the get item method of the
raw data set starts off by returning a
python dictionary
and then after applying set format we
change get item to return data frames
instead
the datasets library also provides a two
pandas method if you want to do the
format conversion and slicing of the
data set in one go
and once you have a data frame you can
find the answers to all sorts of complex
questions or make plots with your
favorite visualization library
only thing to remember is that once you
are done with your pandas analysis you
should reset the output format back to
arrow tables
if you don't you can run into problems
if you try to tokenize your text because
it is no longer represented as strings
in a dictionary
by resetting the output format we get
back arrow tables and we can tokenize
without problem